so again all together this virus is it's
it's a mean little sucker in certain
ways you know sorrows and MERS which
have much higher mortality starts a 10%
immortality mercy like 50 30 percent and
Ebola has 50% a virus that kills more
and kills faster is actually easier to
control then a virus that kills slower
kills less and spreads a symptomatically
so again all these reasons why is just
so difficult Eric welcome to shoma thank
you how do be here
pleasure to have you on this must feel
like a war zone for you at the moment
yeah this epidemic it's been raging um I
think the world woke up to it somewhere
in late January but it's it's gotten
really really bad since when we just
when we think it couldn't get worse it's
gotten worse like just yesterday the
total mortality the total number of
deaths outside of China actually
exceeded the daily deaths inside of
China like the curves of crossed so now
the epidemic is actually worse outside
of China and it's not stopping well I'm
glad that I've got a hold of yourself so
that you can try and give us some signal
to cut through the noise that everyone
has been seeing online I recently saw
Shane Parrish who's doing the same thing
he's got some coronavirus experts on and
the most common question that people are
asking is is to do with trying to work
out where the [ __ ] ends and the
information begins right so before we
get started
who are you why should we listen to you
yeah so I'm a public health scientist
I've been a faculty at Harvard for many
years and actually resigned my faculty
run for Congress but that's a different
story
but I really enjoyed science
communication and you know public policy
and advocacy and especially raising
alarm about this my daughter was in
epidemiology so the science of epidemics
and although I I did other chronic
do you not you know infectious disease
epi it's still in my wheelhouse
and I think sometimes in the world you
know getting the message out there is
something that many scientists are not
good at they know so much in their
technical area that that translating it
for the world and making the masses
listen is something that's now usually
taught and so it's something I really
enjoyed and especially for this pandemic
now I think waking people up and waking
them up early before the tsunami hits is
something we have to do in public health
and we have to do way better so this is
why I'm tweeting non-stop about this
Copa 19 and trying to make everyone
listen I get it yeah it's um it's
interesting that some of the people that
are the best qualified to tell us the
technicalities and the specifics about
what's happening perhaps aren't the best
qualified to communicate that out right
and that's that I get what you mean when
you say about that was that okay let's
start what is coronavirus and what Cove
in nineteen is that the same thing
no coronavirus is the family of viruses
it's like when someone who drives a
certain brand of car but they have
different makes and models coronavirus
is one family and you know the common
cold there's a few kernel viruses that
common cold but there's although common
cold that's other viruses SARS is a
corona virus MERS which is Middle
Eastern respiratory disease a couple
years ago also corona virus and it's
it's one of those little viruses had
these spiky you know aura around its
corona so it looks like it has a corona
around the virus particle on the
microscope but it's an RNA virus but
it's not a it's our retrovirus like like
HIV is HIV is an RNA virus that has to
convert to DNA live in your DNA merge in
your DNA and then replicate its RNA we
directly replicates it's virus particles
after in Bates okay yeah and so this is
a this sub iris that it made a jump from
animals we're probably a bat or some
other animal to humans and there's a lot
of genetic evidence showcasing that
there's no evidence as showcases there
or sort of supports that it's a
bioengineer bio weapon whatsoever
because the more you go you can do this
there's these detective clues they can
see within the DNA within their own
genome the RNA genome that suggests it
was evolutionary driven not as opposed
to some human kind insertion so that's
that's the first myth-busting there that
this is created by the Chinese
government to drive the price of gold up
or something like that yeah
there's no absolutely no evidence
whatsoever and there were some studies
that you know put out that idea in an
unpublished preprint manner
I even tweeted about it because I
thought oh it's it's published but it
was retracted and once it was retracted
I deleted as well and and that's all the
thing like there's a lot of even so
there's bad websites but there's also
like these pre-publication websites that
are not reliable because they're not
peer reviewed and anyone can publish
onto them and information is tricky um
and I I think people need a filter and
you know like putting debunking articles
right after someone posts it I think
it's really key in this day and age um
so yeah it's it's not bioengineering by
weapon well if there is there's no
evidence to date about that but at the
point right now is look it's it's
clearly a virus it's jumped from animals
to humans that's pretty clear and we
right now are just trying to focus on
solving you know we can discuss and
debate how it jumped later but I think
right now that's that's not the most
important thing as part of the epidemic
that you so other different strains are
we talking about one thing toven
nineteen so strains you know strangers
like is it there are different kind of
branching but all that branching
evidence has shown that the all branch
pretty recently in some time in November
so it was one single event that has
since spawned all these different small
variations so we there are like a bit or
variation here and there like for
example the variation in Washington
state is different from this variation
that was in Iran but we know the British
one in British Columbia that was tested
after from the woman who flew from Iran
came from Iran Iran came from Wuhan
while it the Singapore and Japanese and
Korean ones came from a different
branching and so using that kind of
evidence we can actually instead of
asking where did you fly you can
actually look at the virus genome
deceived where did this version come
from like British Columbia Vancouver is
very close to Seattle right you think
that maybe the Seattle version the
Washington state version is the same one
no dickly come from different locations
because of air travel so you can
actually you know use detective work in
its genome to see where originally came
from as opposed to you know just asking
where do you travel
I guess it's useful right it allows you
to see the footsteps of why why this has
been okay so we know that about the
different strains what are the biggest
misinterpretations so father you've seen
besides those conspiracy theories
I think the misinterpretation the it's
just a flu that's actually uh someone a
lot of actually early on a lot of public
health officials and policymaker just
said it's just a flu it's not just a flu
because a everyone has partial immunity
to various strains of the flu
no one has immunity the corona but
there's novel coronavirus kovat nineteen
but the virus is called SARS Cove - the
disease is called Kogut 19 the virus
causes disease code 419 it's it sighs
it's an analogy as HIV causing AIDS
right each IVs the virus a disease so
but you know people just call Koba 19 so
this some
this virus I think the main you know
misconception first of all is that it's
just the flu is very dangerous because
we have a we have vaccines for the flu
in each year that we may pick the wrong
strains to put into the vaccine but it's
still at least partially effective right
anywhere from fifty to eighty percent
effective against most of strains we
don't have a vaccine whatsoever and we
don't have background immunity from you
previously having the flu for free we
see this virus and secondly the flu has
a mortality of point one percent this
one has a mortality of a full one to
three percent that is 10 X 2 3 X higher
xxx 10 X 2 30 X higher so they're not in
that in the same order of magnitude
mortality granted there could be some
places like Singapore with super high
wealthy health care that could actually
you know the mortality could drop below
1% but on average you know W Joe said is
3.4 percent on so far and that's pretty
scary personally so again it's not on
the same scale flu we don't have vaccine
we don't have countermeasures so it's
not the flu and that annoys me to no end
when people say it's just the flu and
also finally the other thing is the
transmission the transmission
reproductive number which means they are
not for every infected person that
person will infect for the flu 1.3 more
people for this virus it's two to four
additional people if you think about it
you know that is one of the fastest
exponential rises you can potentially
find now granted there are things like
measles that have higher are not sub in
the teens but yes well we have a 99%
effective vaccine against the measles
all you have to do is take it so we
again for something with no vaccine
whatsoever this is a very high or not
and as a doubling time around one week
which is is a pretty fast doubling time
for in terms of transmission epidemic so
altogether
it's not the flu in terms of other
misinformation you know some people say
that men get sicker more than women I
would say this partly true men get
infected at the same rate as women but
it could be and but men seem to have a
slightly higher mortality but that's
from a study in China in which men like
70 percent of men in China smoke and so
if you smoke obviously this thing is
gonna kill you faster so is it because
the that it hurts men more is it because
men also smoke more we haven't figured
that out so I don't know if it's and
there's no genetic variation I think you
know you know right now people are
coming down in Europe and people are
dying in in Washington State in the US
and they're not Asian whatsoever so I
don't think there's any racial
explanation of why you know there's no
racial but a difference isn't there um
yeah and the other mysterious thing yeah
we actually is actually true is children
don't seem to get sick from this well
they get infected and they get maybe a
mild sniffle but almost all children who
are infected have very mild to almost no
symptoms which is internal wakes good
but very strange but it's well
established oh and the finally the main
differential between this virus and SARS
and the flu is this coat a SARS Coby to
Koba 19 is transmittable while it's
asymptomatic SARS we were able to stop
in nine months without any vaccine
whatsoever this one that's not gonna be
able to happen because you know say you
take a plane right you're healthy
healthy get off the plane two days later
you get sick develop your symptoms well
with SARS and many other viruses well
it's okay you only got sick two days
after we don't we're not worried about
everyone else that you traveled with but
for this one it's tricky because you can
actually shed viruses
even when before you'd have the symptoms
and so that is very tricky and very
difficult for containment of the
epidemic because how an epidemic works
is that how containment quarantine works
is that you find a case you contact
trace and you quarantine them and
hopefully you quarantine enough but
based on a seven-day kind of thing it's
uh there's a lot of asymptomatic
transmission that could have happened so
again all together this virus is it's
it's a mean little sucker in certain
ways you know sorrows and MERS which
have much higher mortality stars to ten
percent mortality MERS a like 50 30
percent and Ebola has 50 percent a virus
that kills more and kills faster is
actually easier to control then a virus
that kills slower kills less and spreads
a symptomatically
so again all these reasons why is just
so difficult
Joey I want to loop back around to a few
the things you brought up there but one
of them is the current mortality rate
which you've said between 1 and 3
percent I've heard and read some stuff
talking about the fact that that is the
numerator that we've got on the top but
the denominator on the bottom due to
some testing your questions may be
different and if that numerator on the
bottom turns out to be significantly
higher than we've thought because the
reported cases in some places yet the
reported cases in some cases are people
that are symptomatic or symptomatic and
you know the people that died from it
are only people that died from it from
the people who had symptoms whereas it
could be people who died from it versus
people who were just infected and that
number could be much higher could you
take us through that so very good
question and epidemiologist have thought
of that there's two different things
there's there's a tug of war happening
the what you're talking about is under
diagnosis basically mild people or
asymptomatic people they're just not
tested and therefore they don't they
don't show up in the denominator of
total
total cases right and this
underdiagnosis
you know was a problem for in China for
a while and there's it's still a problem
in almost every country other than Korea
Korea is doing 15,000 tests a day drive
through style well they're Korea's got
drive through tests drive through test
in doing 15,000 tests a day holy [ __ ]
same breed it's Korea's you you need a
company country that is like
systematically you know well-managed
enough centrally and you have the wealth
and you have the capacity for the
scientific labs to do the United States
came and do that United States can
probably you know across all its labs to
only like 9,000 and that's across the
entire United States right now at the
moment hopefully we can do more but when
our capacity is not even close to Korea
so my point is under diagnosis oh by the
way Chinese numbers are different than
other numbers because if you test
positive and you don't have symptoms
China does not put you on the confront
case count everywhere else if your test
positive regardless of symptoms your
case account so there's under diagnosis
which if the number at the bottom of
this case fatality ratio is larger then
the case fatality will drop in
percentage right but there's another
competing thing and that is the
mortality lag so this disease is a
long-ass sucker mild cases are about 80%
80% mild to moderate and the duration of
mild cases is two weeks which is by the
way pretty long because most people who
have a flu just get over it in a week
but severe cases which is 20% severe and
critical 20% is about 3 to 6 weeks long
and and some of the critical people who
are basically need hospitalization in
nice you you know they have a 28-day
mortality of 50% in China and China by
the way has a lot of enta leaders they
can manufacture a lot of ventilators and
they have staff ICU staff nurses but the
issue is the three
squeeze it means you have a lot of cases
once you're diagnosed say someone was
diagnosed during Valentine's Day after
kissing terrible Valentine's Day but
their their outcome does not resolve to
a death or recovery for at least six
weeks or three to six weeks you see that
there's a lag from the day that it you
have to think of a cohort you can't
think of it of mortality a simple back
of a napkin calculation of death sorrows
over cases you have to look at it from a
cohort perspective and the problem is a
lot of most countries you know China
still have the people have not recovered
you know and in Korea I would still say
like 80% of cases are neither deaths nor
recover them you know released you've
you've healed yourself you don't virus
you're over in most two-thirds of them
or three-fourths have not been death or
recovered which means they're still part
of this I'm still sick and still have
symptoms or I'm still testing positive
I'm not clear from my body and that
actually causes two problems one the lag
meaning this numerator is not finished
right is not fit this cohort this
valentine's a cohort of everyone who got
on Valentine will not be finished until
end of March early April
so we cannot finish calculating the case
fatality then if we just keep testing
testing more we're just adding more
people to the denominator but who have
not finished the entire disease course
so this is a tug-of-war under diagnosis
would drag the CFR down but the
mortality lag of incomplete resolution
of most of the cases because they
haven't hit it in yeah this case
fatality is only finalized when everyone
is either dead or fully recovered and
that has not happened for most cases yet
guys and they balance out to around 1 to
3 percent depending on the mall and the
other key implication of the disease
being three to six weeks in 20% of
people which is a lot one in five people
have a three to six week a disease
course is hospital beds will be
completely swamped like the United
States
terrible but Korea has a really high per
capita number of hospital beds really
high Korea is like top five you know
there's you know this is why trying to
build a hospital in ten days right in
Korea you know does not have not beds
and most countries do not have not beds
and it's just gonna jam up the
healthcare system it's it's terrible in
that sense that seems pretty ugly why
don't you tell us what the virus does
what does it do I heard it's bad for
people that smoke and it's somewhat to
do with COPD what what is it it's an
ammonia causes bio it's a bar on the
moon so it will give you a fever at
first you have coughing it's common and
then you have you know you feel like
your fluid in your lungs you have
trouble breathing and then and over time
you can an infection can set in further
of your lungs and not sure if it creates
lung scarring there's China did one lung
transplant someone with co19 but it's
it's it's unclear but you only need that
be a permanent lung scarring and most
pneumonia doesn't do that but if the
pneumonia is bad enough you know you
have problems getting oxygen and that's
why people aren't ventilator respirator
machines because they need oxygen and
the and if it just causes it's really
really bad pneumonia people just are
oftentimes dying for lack of oxygen
that's the truth so we've said that
children somehow appear to be fairly low
in terms of symptomatic who are the
people that are the highest so I'm gonna
give you two answers in terms of death
elderly definitely have the highest
death if you think analyzer the curve
goes up like this it's not like a steps
on a step function it's not true yeah
yeah it curves up and it curves up
starting around age 50 and then you know
definitely above 65 it becomes a high
risk like in nursing home in Washington
State there's been six deaths already in
a nursing home of frail elderly people
it's it's really bad and in just one
week
but in terms of the other thing is just
cuz you don't die actually you know it's
tricky in terms of healthcare system
made the same someone who dies quickly
actually it's cheaper for the healthcare
system and for insurance someone who's
sick for six months Oh for six weeks
that's actually really really bad right
because it jams up hospital beds ICU
services etc and so I think you can't
just look at ICU a lot of young people
were actually stuck in ICU as well for
this it's you know in terms of their
earliest reports in China there was just
as many people under the age of 60 is
over the age of 60 in 90 you presumably
on the ventilator this is uh this is a
really serious issue because look people
being sick for a long time is actually a
really really taxing thing on the
healthcare system and I think the other
thing is you know there's also many
young Chinese doctors have died there's
a 29 year old 29 year old 34 year old 42
year old like that's four doctors like
basically 40 or under it's it's very
troubling so and the other thing is just
cuz you're apart of the eighty percent
who have a mild and moderate case you're
still spreading it you're not most
likely those people were not tested are
the eighty percent but they're spreading
and young people you know old people
stay home and watch TV or playing
checkers or something young people are
out and about going to work bartending
waitressing going to movies sports games
know go into restaurants there are the
ones spreading around and so in certain
in certain ways you know their morbidity
may be less but in the they actually add
to the total number of people infected
so these infectious eighty percent miles
is actually much harder to control
because again if even if 20% only 227 I
think is
SiC these 80 percent keeps spreading and
amplifying the total denominator for
people who are who can come down with
something really serious yeah
that's why I don't think just cuz it's
mild for you doesn't make this virus any
better for the general population I
understand yeah um so we touched on it
that and you mentioned it earlier on I
really want to try and get some
definitive ideas about when your
infectious period begins how long the
onset is likely to take before you are
either symptomatic or none symptom Ike
and then when you could release yourself
into the world yeah yeah good question
so this is actually a project that I'm
working on because right now based on
the early studies and we don't have
incubation time for everyone incubation
is that defined at the moment you got
infected to the moment you develop
symptoms and sometimes you can't you
don't know when someone first got
infected so not every case has this
information but the limited numbers we
have it says anywhere between five to
ten days five to seven days
but that means that's just the mean half
them are longer than that and right now
all the quarantine rules are basically
quarantined someone who is exposed or 14
days traveling entering the country
quarantine 14 days the question is is
you know there's a normal distribution
right and if the mean is at five to
seven days the question is are you sure
that by extending it to 14 days
quarantine you've captured the entire
tale because what if this tale centered
on five to seven has a very very long
tail and let's just say 10% of the
people exceed 14 days incubation so that
which means oh I'm perfectly healthy for
14 days I'm gonna be release on the 15th
day they could still develop it if they
have a long queue patient I'm on the
18th or 20th thing okay and then you've
because the quarantine time is
supposedly if you pass this quarantine
time and you haven't gotten sick we can
release you into the wild right
you don't have disease how go
fun again but the question is I don't
know if it's long enough and there's
some studies of showing someone with 21
days or 25 days or something like that
now I don't know if they're there
misreported but it's concerning because
is 14 days fully capturing 99.9 percent
of all people cuz if you just let one
person out now one person can have a
super spreading event you know I've
heard I've heard that term used before
super spreading in super spreaders what
is that yeah so on average one person
you know I told you the are not one
person affects two to four right a super
spreader is some like some unusual
circumstance there's one person is
spreading to tons of people like you
know five to ten to 20 people like this
super spreading event is like a sick
bartender who serves everyone at a party
yeah yeah yeah and then that person does
not just transmit to the average of two
to four you know three but it's
spreading feel like the whole party and
from there you know it gets loose and so
that's a super spreading event and this
person who does it is a super spreader
so I've got it's nothing to do with
someone's particular physiology or the
strain of the virus that they've got
it's more to do with lifestyle and and
your way do they interact unusual
circumstances so there was another super
spreading event years ago in the stars
first SARS epidemic in which um there
was a toilet system in a Hong Kong
building and the toilet system was out
gassing septic gas and which held the
virus particle and we went to the
ventilation system and went into the
whole infected the whole building Holly
[ __ ] that is a bad thing happen I hate
to say there's a study that basically
now it's not of this new virus this is
too new of the old SARS virus someone
didn't study and they realize that
obviously you can spread it from a
droplet sneeze right or talking at
dinner time to someone um but apparently
it's also in the fecal
matter which means in they did this
study of flatulence is the virus
particle in the flatulence and the
flatulence you know it can go pretty far
now I wouldn't say this on camera on TV
but weird podcast oh yeah we can say
whatever you want Eric let's let's start
to debate about whether or not we can
fart our way to a pandemic yes is I will
send you the link it is there is someone
did a study they should win you know the
Nobel for this but they actually showed
that the virus particle can actually
travel quite far if you if you leave a
very very long trail so now it's not for
this current virus but it's for the old
SARS virus it's a sister corona virus
how likely is it that it's gonna be out
it's gonna have the same capability yeah
I think it's likely because there's
issue in the Hong Kong last month as
well and someone who is living someone
was self quarantine at home but someone
was living like several floors beneath
them got infected and and they found
that it was also something related to
septic gas
so we've spoken about the fact that it's
to do with at least mostly droplets I've
heard something to do with like it's not
airborne but that waterborne what does
this mean how do how do I get it it's
like a lot of these droplets when you
sneeze like a - it actually goes pretty
far it doesn't have to be fully airborne
airborne now there's some argument that
it couldn't be airborne I think the jury
is still out
so what's the demons that's the
difference between a bond a bond and
water droplets well water droplets will
eventually settle right
airborne means like it will stay in the
air and will flow in the air like a
balloon right well obviously it's me
particle but stay in the air but you
know a droplet means these tiny things
like when he sneeze on you when you
speak it comes out of your mouth but
over time it will settle down so it's
like semi flying in the air for a short
distance and so we're sure about that
now fully airborne
it's hard to say there's some study that
says yes I'm sorry that says no but in
the I think the main thing is close
contact close [ __ ] and I think the close
contact issue we've seen it
also we think a lot of the for example
the shift of diamond cranes princess
ship it was a petri dish literally to
grow and a lot of people you know one in
four one in five to wonder for people on
that ship has tested positive which is
insane you know that ship has three
thousand seven hundred people and one in
four wanted by people as test positive
and the reason we think of that is
because a lot of people who are in the
inner cabins besides the food sharing
and you know public but people within
our cabins do you don't have like a
window and so their ventilation system
now is it or is it like droplet travel
through the system okay so we let's say
that word with someone we're talking to
them we've got that concern what about
if I touch my mouth and I've got it and
then I put my hand on a doorknob or
something how long can it live on a
doorknob yeah you can live a week a we
yeah a week that's a long time yeah it's
up to a week it depends on certain
things like temperature and humidity it
degrades faster in in warmer and more
humid air but at the same time you know
we're not like Singapore happen epidemic
you Singapore 7075 degrees you know
that's like 20 25 degrees Celsius and so
that still happened but that these were
mostly indoor people Singapore epidemic
happened the super spreading event was
at a Grand Hyatt Hotel Singapore in that
hotel
you know hotels it doesn't really matter
what the outside climate is right if you
had an indoor conference center or
indoor gym and you get it it doesn't
matter what it is outside so you know I
think that one of the misinformation
actually is about oh it's gonna all go
when the summer comes it's gonna be too
hot except we are indoor workplace kind
of people and there's something called
the southern hemisphere the earth and
then you'll just go to in Africa and
Australia and you know Indonesia and
when this is wintertime in the north in
the summertime in the north and
wintertime and south so I don't think
that it's gonna go away in the summer
arguments you might slow down a little
but it could easily come back in the
fall oh that's that's the tricky part
the the virus seems to be a survivor
basically can containment work or we
just passed us to UM containment you
know a lot of people say w chose still
trying to be optimistic the containment
can work but I think I think we we have
we have to move from containment to
mitigation
now you did that lots of different
mitigation is just you know reducing the
number of people who are exposed and no
and you know you test as much as you can
but in terms of actually stopping the
virus you just you mitigate its impact
and you mitigate its spread but
containment just means preventing a
community transmission event right
someone is someone trapped to travels
from say Iran lands at the airport
and then they we detect that they're
sick and we quarantine them then that is
contained right but if they can't come
back
go send infects your kids goes a daycare
childcare goes to a party infects
everyone and they all go home and they
all test positive and they all don't
know necessarily where they had gotten
it it's not containing any more its
community transmission and community
transmission is way more dangerous than
a travel related thing because it means
they picked it up randomly in the
community of an unknown source that we
can't necessarily trace anymore
okay so when does it get to the point
where
we need to just buy all of the rice in
Costco and not leave our house I think
depending on which country you are we're
already there I mean it's not realistic
do I need to do I need to do that like
you know I don't think there's any cases
in New Castle where I am like she'll be
worried about going where you are yeah
yeah I don't think you can I think Italy
is there it ran at least having a bad
time at the moment Italy really is bad
Seattle right now is having a really bad
one the Seattle area
you know Amazon Amazon has many
buildings but one of their buildings
that does Amazon fresh Amazon Prime now
it's called the Amazon Brazil building
it holds like over to 3,000 workers in
this huge building somewhat that's a
positive on February 25th and they had
to send a notice to everyone like and
the epidemic is so bad widespread in
Washington that I think they may have to
shut down schools soon they might have
to cancel all public events like some
places you have to put these moratoriums
on on public gatherings and think some
places like Italy Zardo Italy just
canceled schools today for like at least
two weeks maybe longer yep nationwide I
think Washington State may have to do
that as well Dubai Dubai already has
yeah no but I think this is this is
where you know mitigation comes in
because you're not containing anymore
you know it's there we just have to you
know lockdown people and I it does work
social distance until we have the
vaccine which will take a year to 18
months a year for lucky and hopefully
the vaccine is is high enough act like a
60 70 percent effective vaccine might
not be enough to stop this virus
remember for every infected person it
may infect two to four additional people
so you need to get the are below one and
so with that you know you
you know something that say our or three
you need like Lisa you know 70% higher
just to bring it below one you know you
need a very high you need 85 90 95
percent efficacy and not every vaccine
is the perfect efficacy like that so and
then that is only a year and a half
there are existing antiviral drugs that
could work
there were testing this there's some
older HIV and hepatitis C drugs we're
currently testing the drug does exist
it's then phase one tested but we have
to Phase two test whether it works with
this virus again that might take six to
nine months we couldn't get early
results depending on how good it is
in late April at the earliest so we'll
have to see I get you okay um how can I
tell if I've got Cove in nineteen
without going to hospital where I am
might the hospitals might already be
over capacity or whatever how do I know
um because the symptoms are very
nonspecific at first you know fever
coughing you know pneumonia but there's
many things that cause that right so um
you need to get tested but at the same
time you know testing capacity is very
limited so again which you could what if
someone has something it could be the
flu it really could or can be another
endemic common cold can rotavirus that's
not nearly so bad you can't really tell
until you're totally tested you could
get a CT and it will tell you a CT will
pick up a really bad pneumonia in your
lungs but that's more of an
approximation again it's not for certain
in who bait anyone who tested positive
for CT pneumonia they assume you have it
but because that's because you're in
wuhan right that is thinner but most you
have to go okay
that that seems like it's not as easy as
it could be or should be I suppose let's
talk about let's talk about the
origin just for a second I want to get
back to how people that are listening
can potentially protect themselves and
then potentially some public policy
implications as well but um there's been
some talk I've seen quite a bit of stuff
about we need to find the origin patient
zero is important is finding patient
zero important the person that it jumped
from animals to humans at this point
it's not the most important thing at all
patient zero would I give you a source
initially but at this point for all the
treatments in containment and public
health measures it's it's of low
importance you know and so people keep
asking was it the seafood Markey or not
you know I would say that it might not
be the seafood market only because you
know the New England Journal paper
actually found that the first two people
infected in early December had no
seafood market contact it was only the
next wave that had seafood market
contact in in late December so it could
have been that someone introduced it to
the seafood market and seafood market
was like this super spreading event
right so you know but whether it was
introduced to supermarket or it was Jame
to jump from the animal to humans that
add the zebra market it doesn't really
make that much of a difference I don't
think um you know the only people who
really care are the the bio weapon
conspiracy theories yeah yeah yeah it's
a moot point we know that we know that
these there's tons of you know there's a
study in which people study about how
many corona viruses are in bats oh my
god there's like dozens and dozens that
we've never even known about and so then
they tested the blood of all these
people these in dishes indigenous people
and local rural tribes are exposed to
these bats and they found oh my god
these people actually have a lot of
corona virus that never been identified
before they just been mild and we've
ignored it because it's not bad but this
one is actually a really bad one because
it's selected itself for you know over
time
the most the survival the fittest in
terms of viral of evolution so this we
have now viral evolution selected one of
the most infectious severe viruses and
it is perfectly natural and possible and
plausible they happen by itself
have we had any indication that this
virus could mutate and is that concern
does it matter
and what does it mean yeah so it can
mutate RNA viruses mutate more than DNA
viruses that's it's like a general rule
because RNA system is always a little
funky because DNA has two helixes right
and so if you make an error the other
keylex realizes the error and something
fixes it right away
the RNA is a single strand so it doesn't
have this correction mechanism but the
corona virus has is is a big enough RNA
they actually has a special endo nucleus
within it they actually can have fix
errors along the way so it doesn't
mutate as fast as the flu the flu has a
very funky mutation system that tries to
always reshuffle itself and create some
brand new strains every year that causes
vaccines that always have to play a
whack-a-mole catch-up but hopefully we
can have one vaccine that will work for
this it doesn't so you know we haven't
you know we have different variations
small variations and they found that the
actual mutation rate is one mutation one
approximately one amino acid a mutation
every two weeks so that's how they
figured out that's the proximate rate
and so you can figure out how how it
diverges you know you know the detective
sleuthing I of the virus genome I told
you about earlier but it's it's not
we're not gonna get multiple strains and
it couldn't eat eight but at the same
time you could most mutations are just
junk mutations you could potentially
select for a very hyper survival one but
generally you need a very high
infections for that and right now
overseas there's still not enough of
that I I don't think the mutation is our
current worry you know I think we will
be able to find one vaccine that will
work for it for a long time it's so it's
not like the flu in that sense don't you
um right what are some of the things
that the people who are listening can do
to protect themselves
what's the 80/20 on that I will stop
shaking hands with people no offense
we've hired them this bump oh boo bump I
saw I'm sorry for sorry for putting in
here but I saw a relative transmission
rate graph which I'm going to presume
that you've seen and it's like the elbow
bump was best then followed by the fist
bump and then there was like the slow
fist bump I'm like who's doing a slow
fist bump like you from Saved by the
Bell in the 1990s or something I think
that's just one measure I think the
other key things are you know just don't
touch your face by the way really
embarrassing at Washington State there
was a press conference about the
epidemic and as she was fumbling through
her papers she she would say everyone to
wash your hands don't touch your face
she was flipping her paper and like the
thing is to middle the press conference
telling people don't touch their face it
was terrible what it what it what is it
it's not a facepalm is it it's like face
yeah doing a facepalm that's the problem
oh yeah I know anyways it's common the
internet meme all right now but it's
it's just so terrible but I think you
know avoid touching elevator buttons
just avoid touching doorknobs I know
that is really hard but doorknobs are
not disinfected often don't touch things
in public you have to kind of be a
little germaphobe until this thing is
over you know and public transit is the
other thing like I see like this you
know the city leaders are always saying
public transit is fine but public
transit is also one the
a confined space limited ventilation you
know what I'm talking about
and it doesn't have unlike the airplane
airplane at least it takes in new air
every three or five minutes so the air
in in the cabins being replaced every
three to five minutes
so in certain ways the airplane is
pretty good unless you get unlucky and
sit someone next took off the airplane
is actually pretty good in terms of
replacing the air but that's not true on
a bus or a train you know and so and I
don't know if they use super high small
micron HEPA filters that can filter out
virus particles it's not every air
filter does so uh you know I think the
other key thing is people ask do travel
I say look at some point you know once
the pandemic becomes really real and
it's like in what's really real me as in
like the epidemic is literally
everywhere any you know let's just say
if I was in United States
it's an eighty percent of all the states
you know I'm gonna say it's probably
everywhere and staying here is no better
than getting on a plane and going there
granted you know Airport is uh is a
place exchange but I don't think I don't
think you should stop your life and
people ask me how anxious I mean my aunt
on a scale one to ten I'm a six I'm
worried but I'm not anxious because I'm
anxious about things that is something I
can control them not doing right like
testing I'm anxious that we're not
getting enough testing but am i anxious
for the inevitable inevitable because
the CDC one a CDC vaccine immunology
head says report report to Congress this
virus is in that evitable it will be in
every single state in that sense I am
NOT anxious because it's like just brace
yourself come what may right so I have
that kind of stoic mentality obviously
not everyone does but you know protect
yourself as much as you can as for masks
surgical masks are pretty useless and
n95 masks do not filter out and
everything but n95 masks are better but
at the same time if you wear beard it's
totally useless wearing some n95 masks
by the way began a beautiful full a full
steel and certain again the surgical
mask the mask what they mostly do is it
catches your spray from your mouth when
you're talking to someone hey how's it
going to have a great idea and you're
spraying you know even if you're someone
who's very careful everyone sprays just
alive or when they talk at dinner time
it's natural but it does not actually
protect you from inhaling the virus if
it's you know droplet tiny droplet in
the air does that make sense
so like it will some sometimes people
have a false sense of security when they
wear a mask it's not it's it's actually
protect others not to protect yourself
necessarily okay oh I thought I could
just stick a stick it must gonna not be
okay so it turns out that that's that's
not very good so what about um helping
my mask or partially effective they are
partially but they're also now in the
highest demand No yes
gang hold it I just got told before this
by one of my friends the arm alcohol
hand wash prices like some companies
charging like 10x hundred X well it
should be you know no there's a lot of
price gouging although there's actually
like do-it-yourself like home home hand
sanitizer they can make out isopropyl
alcohol you saw so okay that's cool
that's pretty cool you just paid you to
be able to search on on the internet and
figure out how to make your own hand
sanitizer um it's probably shell flies
to builds he probably not as good but
you just mix some aloe vera gel and this
alcohol and you could it's it's good
enough um that's that's a really good
that's a really good tip I like that
what about um ensuring that I am as
robust as I can be
I shall be hoping my vitamin d3 should I
be you know yeah some people say take
your vitamin C vitamin D and vitamin D
is good for general immunity vitamin C
can maybe you know shorten of a cold to
short of small amount but we don't have
evidence I'm a scientist I'm an
epidemiologist I also do clinical trials
unless you have causal evidence I'm hope
the jury's still out in my sense problem
I don't harm in doing it but there's
also no no indication that it's gonna
work well don't go panic buying on these
things without evidence
that's my generals like don't go panic
buying also by the way is more of a
somatoform ik social phenomena
if you see someone panic by at the store
you're gonna panic by but if you see
someone just buying one or two you're
just gonna buy one or two right it's
it's a panic buying is is you see other
panicking people panicking and then you
panicking and then that's all stampedes
happen that's how people people die in
stampedes right yeah because oftentimes
it's other people running and so all of
a sudden you have to run to or else
you're gonna be trampled so it's
society's a funny awful place and it is
with these weird shaven Apes walking
around with a brain that really doesn't
work right for them environment it's in
I got a couple more questions first off
we've spoken it's been in the nicest way
possible Eric you haven't told me what I
wanted to hear but I'm glad that you've
told us what you know what would be an
indication to two-part question first
part what would be an indication that
things are getting worse the vacation
that it's getting worse is if you start
if the epidemic is unchecked even in a
high-income country like Germany Sweden
Finland Denmark
what does unchecked mean like community
transmission like really fast community
transmission in those kind of places I
would I
would really start to worry because you
know those places have some of the best
health care systems and the other signal
is in Korea if the mortality you know
how I talked about the cohort your
senior Valentine's Day infected person
by the end of March
if the mortality is still pretty high
then I'm gonna still be pretty worried
about about it because the mortality is
like above 1% even in Korea that's
that's pretty bad in my sense okay what
would be an indication that things are
getting better um the community
transmission stopping and I want to see
you know high number of tests and then
high number tests the proportion
infected a steadily declining assuming
the same constant number of tests that
would be a good signal because the more
you test or at a high test volume you're
not you're not finding more that means
um potentially the the epidemic is
winding down I just want to say that the
test is not perfect the test has a
accuracy about 50 percent or less which
means not that there's false positives
if you test the positive it's most
likely a pretty much clear it's positive
there's a lot of false negatives and the
false negatives is not an issue when
you're first diagnosing a case as much
you know early on it's really important
to catch every case but at least is
catching a case catching at least 50% of
cases is better than catching none right
the problem of this high number of false
negatives is that when you it's time to
release people from either quarantine or
from the hospital their fever is gone
their symptoms are resolved and right
now oftentimes you need two consecutive
a one full day apart negative tests 2
consecutive negative tests
but the problem is um you can easily
have you know 50% times 50% you could
have a 25% chance just by pure luck that
you get negative tests right um and I
don't and that worries me because seems
now out there spreading it round yeah
thinking that fine and because there's
many examples someone tested negative 7
times released tested positive a week or
two that's an actual example oh my god
there's like five or six examples in
China in Japan this happened so many
times just look right now they call
reinfection it's this it's I don't think
it's reinfection misdiagnosis it's just
you were released on based on negative
tests that are that are faulty okay and
then and then over time you know say you
get sleep-deprived one night and you had
a stressful day and then your system
drops a little bit and then the virus
flares back up um
but you never shed it like this happens
all the time like for example HIV HIV
test sometimes they say oh the drug was
so effective it is below the limit of
detection we can't detect the virus but
we know it's still there so this kind of
thing happens all time like you could be
low low low and the test will give you a
negative but the test might not be
sensitive enough to the super low and to
negative tests to release you you still
have it still shedding test positive
later but during that time you may have
infected someone that actually worries
me the most I would love to see a test
with both high sensitivity and high
specificity sensitivity means all the
true cases how many do you find you want
to find nine percent of them high
specificity means all the people who
don't have it how many um percent that
you correct like one minus the false
positive so a false positives 1% the
specificity is 99% you want the
specificity give a test to have high
sensitivity and high specificity and
oftentimes the problem with the US
testing delay was the kit there was
three parts of the kit the first two was
finding the virus the third was a
negative control the negative control
had a whole bunch of other miscellaneous
viruses and the test kit was supposed to
test positive just for the covert 19 the
Czar's code - virus but negative for the
negative control but it somehow cross
reacted and the tests kept testing
positive for even for the ones the
sample that does not have it because
somehow the test is picking up other
viruses as well and that's why the
testing when the US was delayed two
weeks but this testing problem we need
to get a better test but this 50%
accurate one and 50 percent based on
chinese academy of science analysis is
currently the best we have but hopefully
we can find there also a more rapid one
because right now the lab the pcr that
you need a PCR machine so it takes at
least 12 hours to you know buy something
senators allowed get it back and it's
pretty labor-intensive if we have like
an a1c like a glucose drip or
cholesterol you know you basically in
prick stick it in the little strip and
it tells you or something rapid under an
hour that would be really great there
are people working on it but it still
has to go through some approval but um
and then i want to see how accurate this
you know I can only I can only imagine
some of them I mean you're one of them
you're one of the the people that's in
the midst of this particular situation
but I can only imagine how chaotic some
of the guys working at vaccine
laboratories working at the testing
laboratories you know working at the
control set and then take it one step up
from there what about the the doctors
and nurses that are working it's like
every health care professional on the
planet just got turned up to 11 right
yeah you know is it is really stressful
to healthcare professionals and also
first responders like firefighters and
police who first respond to someone who
falls ill and needs 911 see ambulance
and and unless you know that this person
has a respiratory illness who
could be a potential case they're not
you not wearing any protection and the
scary part is with the quarantine
Japanese quarantine officer who boarded
the princess diamond ship you know the
one that was quarantine off of Yokohama
he boarded with mask with protective
gear did inspection got off the ship
tested positive another a firefighter in
Japan transporting these patients as
they were evacuating he was a wearing
protective gear in his transporting test
it tested positive and and so it's
really trouble like right now they're in
one County in next to Seattle Washington
25 firefighters have been quarantine
which is a full quarter of their entire
of firefighting work force out of
commission for 15 days and now half of
them are have developed flu-like
symptoms all from just transporting and
you know there's one patient this virus
is so infectious it is just used coffins
sneeze and it goes everywhere and that's
what's such a worrying little little
sucker so I want to I want to I want to
right back up and just give everyone
what they should take away from this
apart from obviously all the information
and thank you so much for giving us your
time I know that you must be crazy busy
you're on Turkish TV and Iranian BBC and
and ABC and all this stuff the things
that people can do what should they do
give us the principles they should take
away don't panic by slow by your stock
up probably two weeks worth of food and
water in case of future panic by but
remember you're trying to prepare so
power preparing is slow by um avoid
touching people and their voice on your
hands wash you know just generally go
into restaurants be very careful don't
touch anything
basically that's not purely you know
static clean I would avoid social things
I would avoid concerts sports sporting
events parties with poor ventilation
maybe outdoor party maybe but I just no
one seeing how infectious it has been on
so many people different situations
avoiding these kind of things are all
costs public trouble yeah and public
transport be very careful be very
careful if someone coughs next to you
another way but at the same time don't
be racist that you know someone just
because they look like they're from
China at this point looking like you're
someone from China is not an indicator
someone having a virus anymore you know
in that sense you know avoid Italians
but that doesn't make sense either I
think I think just social distancing is
the most important thing I hate to say
it until we have these drugs or a
vaccine social distancing is really the
best measure and again this bumps and
elbow bumps or something like that
just avoid touching people and you know
even at dinner if having faces face
conversation stand as far as way as you
can and and you know at restaurants
people are very careful we need to when
you're going out to dinner and you're
talking your saliva will naturally go
into someone else's food across the
table okay so and if you're gonna do a
podcast do it over Skype like this yeah
we're gonna have these virtual reality
kind of like holograms and then you know
it's gonna feel real because then you
can all if you can if you can infect me
with kovat 19 through a hologram then
technology has gone too far
hey I have an infectious personality I
get it Eric man let us say thank you so
much you are be right in the midst of it
at the moment people want to follow you
for updates and stuff why should they go
yeah follow my Twitter I have a Facebook
as well but right now I'm just purely on
Twitter for this update is at dr. Eric
ting dr Eric
your eye see then ding D ing at dr. Eric
ding fantastic are there any other other
than your Twitter feed obviously are
there any news outlets or or websites or
whatever that you think are giving
accurate updates where people could
follow those as well
I think stat news is really good one
stat news is like a healthcare newspaper
there and they have pretty good updates
you know obviously whu-oh has updates
but WH o their recommendations are much
more optimistic if you want more
realistic in certain ways or more
predictively
ambitious I would say you know follows I
think following Twitter Co V 19 half
stag it's it's a really good hash
because it's something that everyone's
using afford for this epidemic on on
Twitter you know is I try to source
everything that's indirectly sorsa
before month or journalist or a
newspaper so I'm trying to stick to the
facts but I'm giving the real the
realistic things that the health
department people who don't necessarily
want to say out loud so I think
certainly certainly in the environment
that we're in at the moment it makes a
lot of sense to on this side of prudence
rather than optimism with with something
like this right look Eric man thank you
thank you so much for your time I I hope
in the nicest way possible I hope that
we don't need to do another episode
about this I hope so
if always week again we can just be
talking about you know summit cool isn't
that isn't that virus isn't that virus
that all gives us like really really
good skin isn't that like such a such a
wonderful pandemic for us all to have as
opposed to you know how much how much
food you have left next time we are over
in our bunkers well I don't know I do
know where you are if I need to contact
you and let us say if so man it's a I'm
glad that I've got hold of someone who
understands what's going on I hope sure
that a lot of the people that are
listening what do as well thank you so
much and let's let's chat again
hopefully
couple weeks or months
[Music]
you